The Joe Rogan Experience so the real
challenge here is how do we find a way
that means the vast amount so the 6.5
billion people who are not rich can
actually get a great living by the end
of the century and we can also fix
climate change and that's only going to
happen if we find the technological
breakthroughs not by telling everyone
I'm sorry could you do with less not
only is that not going to win any
elections in the long run but it's also
just not going to be possible to
convince China India Africa to do that
now what about the impact on climate
change and natural storms hurricanes and
the like like how much are they
increasing how much is the severity of
them increasing because that's a big
point of confusion for people I've heard
I've heard multiple people say that
those storms are worse than ever and
more frequent than ever and then I've
heard people say no they're actually
less frequent than ever but stronger
I've even heard people say no no they're
more frequent and less strong so I don't
know what's going on no so if the
biggest point on this I think is they're
certainly much stronger on TV right I
mean you hear much much more about them
because they're cells right they're such
great stories yeah they absolutely they
sell but if you actually look at the
data
we cannot tell right now so that's
that's the conclusion from the uh from
the government agencies of the us as
well we can't still tell that there's a
fingerprint from climate change on
hurricanes we can't so no we can't why
can't we because there's such a natural
variability that you can't see oh this
increase or this decrease is because of
global warming is there if you increase
Trend currently well so in the 1960s
sorry in the 1970s and 80s there was a
lull in hurricanes that hit the U.S that
was also when satellite coverage started
so much of what you see now is if you
start from the 1970s or 1980s there is
an increase for the U.S
uh but that's probably uh uh spurious
because if you go back in the 1950s and
1960s there was actually just as many
hurricanes so what you do and this is by
far the best estimate so I actually have
that I brought that with me uh if you
take a look at uh slide four on a in the
a file
uh there we see if you look at the
number of hurricanes that have hit the
U.S because remember we don't know about
this hurricanes that we couldn't see uh
back when we didn't have satellites
right now we see them because we have
satellites but that's obviously the
wrong way to counter to count so if you
just look at the Hurricanes that
landfall on the U.S you get this graph
and so this is 19 1900 to 2022. yeah so
2022 is obviously not done but it's
probably done and it looks incredibly
similar it's actually slightly
decreasing this is not significant
slightly decreasing from 2008 so sorry
no from 2000 from another from 19 if you
try to put in the best line as you can
see that's the dotted Red Line you
actually have a slightly decreasing
lines oh I see that's easy overall the
average yeah the overall average used to
be uh you know more like two hurricanes
per season pass down to 1.6 or something
sorry what the hell was going on in 1980
looks like 86. yeah yeah I was going to
pull up it uh this is a contradicting
chart though okay
it specifies though North Atlantic which
this does not okay so North Atlantic is
where the predominant amount of
hurricanes exist in the United States is
that correct or South Atlantic
it's South Atlantic so North Atlantic
would have less of them because the
water's cold Northern Hemisphere I
believe is not just it's not North
compared to the United States it's North
First South hemisphere oh okay okay why
Atlantic hurricanes are getting stronger
faster than other storms yeah hurricane
Ian 264 since 1980 compared to the globe
according to this chart percentage of
tropical Cyclone activity with major
intensity so major intensity indicates
that the sustained wind speeds reach a
category three level or higher so it
seems like there's more of them yes and
notice what that happens it starts in
1980. and that's why you know when you
when you do these numbers it's very easy
to get this number this result if you
start in 1980 when they were much lower
if I can just show you the other graph
again because I showed you for all of
the Hurricanes but we also have uh if
you take the next slide uh for uh that's
just a strong hurricane so that's
exactly the same as what you just showed
uh category three and and uh uh and uh
higher and what you see here again is
that there are fewer hurricanes not not
more hurricanes hitting the us today
than they used to be back in in the
early part of it I'm just saying there's
only one per year or yes that doesn't
feel like that's right though this is
one major hurricane land falling each
year
yeah is that usually what we get
and so if you go all the way back to
2006 which is that year we were talking
about it looks like there was four
so that so from 80 so when you're
looking at that maybe 2005 that was uh
Hurricane Katrina and all these others
okay so when you're looking at that
other chart that shows the increase from
1980 see with the 1980 it's just all
those years it's just one and then it
gets up to four in 2006.
and that's a rough year so all that
factors into the average and that kicks
the average up to 264 percent but a lot
of it is from 2006. and a lot of it is
because you just you know go from a
period when there was a relative lull to
appear it when it's back up on these
parts what is it differentiating as
major or not major because then we get
to like we almost got through all the
names I thought a couple years ago so
yes sorry uh so major is category three
but these all landfalling remember a lot
of hurricanes are not land falling so
the reason why we run out of names is
because the there we are able to see a
lot more of them so they actually
estimate this is a re-analysis by Noah
and all those guys
um so they actually found that we now
name about four storms more than we
would have named in the early 2000s
every year because we're just become
better at you know notice oh there's a
hurricane and then it dropped uh dropped
off right don't hit not only because
they don't hit but typically they're
just one or two days uh what's the
percentage of them that actually hit the
the the problem is like when they get
strong enough on the ocean that they can
carry over onto the land and devastate
the land so the reason why I'm looking
at landfall is because in the early part
of last century you would have it's very
likely that someone would have noticed a
landfalling hurricane anywhere in the
U.S but if it's out in the middle of
nowhere there's a very good chance
nobody would have noticed actually you
can see in the in the data that when uh
the uh the Panama Canal opened
suddenly uh you know ships started going
a different route so there is a big part
of the Atlantic that they no longer
traversed and so we never so you know
the number of hurricanes dropped in
those areas because you know you need it
to have sort of a ship to be out there
and noticing that's why it's a very very
bad way to look at this if you just look
at how many hurricanes do we know about
because we just know about a lot more
now so that's from satellite radar and
that was what year they started
implementing satellite this is about
1980 1980 okay so that's when okay so so
it's not clear but basically what you're
saying your point was to basically say
what people will are worried about is
that there's going to be a lot more
hurricanes yes well actually so the best
evidence seems to indicate that was one
of the points that you said that there
will probably be fewer hurricanes but
they will be stronger
and overall stronger is worse than fewer
is better
which means that overall they'll be
slightly more damage right so global
warming is bad that's you know one of
the many things that you know will
actually be worse with global warming
but it's not terribly bad it's somewhat
worse and of course at the same time
we're getting much better at dealing
with this impact what you're actually
seeing if you look at the total cost for
instance on on uh on on Hurricane
impacts and all kinds of climate impacts
it's actually going down not up in
percent in percent of GDP why because we
now know we have much better prediction
we know how to you know deal with these
things for instance get a lot of a lot
of stuff that can be moved we get it out
of Harm's Way so every time there's a
hurricane you know all all trucks will
go to other states that kind of thing so
there's a lot of things that don't get
damaged we can also build better as you
talked about uh with houses and so on so
we have a lot of ways to reduce this but
what is happening is it'll reduce
slightly less fast because of global
warming again not the end of the world
but a problem so the fear-mongering
would have you terrified about a future
that's impossible to fix and that we're
doomed and you're you're simply saying
it is a problem but is not our biggest
problem it's it's it's a problem in the
sense that it slows down progress right
and if I can just you know because
people talk a lot about uh the fact that
we won't have enough food either uh I
have I have another slide
um on in the B file and uh
God I need glasses and number six 19
sorry I was just Googling this uh 2020
it says 11 hurricanes made it to land
here a total of 11 named storms made
landfill United States breaking the
previous record of 9 and 1960 11 name
storms or six of these were storms
restricted United States that's
hurricane intensity they were talking
about category three and above that was
that that was just this one though right
his chart which was this is it all
hurricanes this is Major hurricanes
Phoenix what is that so category one
what's the worst is category one the
worst or four no this is the worst right
what's the worst yeah this has four
hurricanes hit us and four and then when
I Google it says there's at least six if
not eleven yeah that's I mean this this
is period literature uh I have noted and
the the updates are for the guy this is
2020 Jamie yeah I just was trying to
pick one year yeah yeah
um
uh and these and the one that this was
saying they're intensifying this is that
like since 1950 only uh nine category
four hurricanes have made hit the
mainland but six of those were in the
last five years whoa
that seems like a problem
that's a big problem
ah it's just doesn't that seem like a
big problem me we're seeing that I would
see why people would freak out okay and
this is so we we can't sit here and do
period research and uh in real time uh
I'm I'm sure but you do need
contradicting oh no no statements
absolutely but I am saying that so I'm
I'm happy to say that we should uh so
there's very little uh four and five
hurricanes that's why the uh the major
and that was also why the other graph uh
showed the change in uh in um in three
three four and we'll go back to that
again please for a second look at that
man Andrew was even more powerful than
Ian in 92.
that was a 165 mile an hour what's the
[ __ ] strongest one that we've ever
had
is that all of them that we've had
during the last uh so that's the last 50
years yeah I think when I was like 92 I
think so Ian was the strongest or Andrew
excuse me was the strongest that was
165. Katrina's not even on this list no
wow why isn't Katrina on the list I
don't know that was a big one wasn't it
yeah wasn't that hurricane three
category three it could have been big
and long and just lasted for a long time
right the devastation was big because of
where it hit yes
wow also if if you look at the major
hurricanes uh uh we had the biggest
drought ever so there were 11 years
where there were no major hurricane that
hit the U.S recently uh I don't know if
you noticed that was when nobody talked
about hurricanes
and then of course the Hurricanes came
back and then we say oh see global
warming again this is how we're not
being well served with this kind of
conversation what is your book called
false alarm false alarm yeah because no
I don't have one yet here thank you very
much
um I don't I wouldn't say false alarm I
would say there's a lot of other [ __ ] to
be worried about as well yes
that's the other book I brought you
prioritizing development yes ah see so
this is this is basically this is what
my day job really is uh because as as
you also know uh and as we talked a
little bit about so look there's a lot
of problems in the world and for most
people so rich people who are you know
well ensconced in their lives and they
you know they don't have to worry about
their kids dying from uh infectious
diseases or or not having enough food
all that kind of stuff they clearly can
worry about what the temperature is
going to be in 100 years but for most of
the planet's population so know the 6.5
billion people here they actually worry
about their kids might die tonight they
might not have enough food they have
terrible education there are all kinds
of other terrible things you know almost
a billion people are extremely poor so
in terms of the overall impact on human
health and life
elevating the economy is the most
important step that people can take it's
certainly a very important part of it
and again when we sorry if I could just
show you the the one of malnutrition the
uh the slide uh from the B stack number
six
sorry so what I just want to show you
was that malnutrition has come down
dramatically and again what you see here
so this is the number of death uh uh
from uh so from kits that are less than
five years old and again this is very
similar to the other chart but a little
bit of a difference the difference
between with climate change and without
climate change without climate change is
only slightly lower but the overall
trend is much much much lower than it
was in 1990. and this is because we're
getting better at you know making
agriculture uh this is what we talked
about before they're much better in
India they're much better everywhere and
the overall net benefit is positive
we're we're moving towards a world
that's going to be much better so these
guys that are protesting think it's the
end of the world no it's not it's a
world that's going to be much better but
they're right in saying that climate is
one problem and we should definitely
think about how we fix that but we
should also remember a large part of
this is how do we fix all the other
problems